he's joined me Sunday night for a
special look at the historic point in
time when Ronald Reagan brought the
message of peace and freedom to what was
then the Soviet Union the program is
called three days in Moscow it's based
on my book three days in Moscow Ronald
Reagan and the fall of the Soviet empire
here's a preview with the man who served
as the president's press secretary at
the time the speech at Moscow University
where president wanted to talk about a
freedom of speech set the stage for that
woman when I walked in the door I looked
up into the head of the church with this
huge statue of Lenin and the lectern
that was set up for Reagan was right in
front of it you're thinking that's a bad
thing I'm thinking it's a horrible thing
yes and President Reagan was smiling and
what I didn't get was President Reagan
saw it as an opportunity to deliver this
message to deliver this freedom under
Lenin's
I never let her die his joke later was
how great was it to have Lenin map to
stare at my backside for an hour and a
half but it turned out to be a perfect
forum for him to deliver his message the
[Music]
students filed in and settled down
Reagan warmed up his audience by wishing
them success in their own language I
know you must be very busy this week
studying and taking your final
examinations so let me just say July you
whose Becca
[Applause]
the our special three days in Moscow
premieres Sunday night 8 p.m. Eastern
Time